[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and if
you saw my reddit ama a couple of days
ago then you saw one of the questions
was i'm trying to start my own youtube
channel i was wondering what equipment
do you use and do you recommend what you
have and my answer 99 of the time is
nope
no like i i don't recommend what i use
on a daily basis to most people like you
might see me prodding austin evans or
someone who does something similar to me
on twitter to switch to red or switch to
the dark side or something like that but
a red weapon or pretty much any cine
camera is total overkill for not just
youtube but for most of what you could
possibly get out of it on the web but i
use stuff like this because i love it i
made a dope tech video all about the red
weapon and why i use it what it's
capable of and things like that but for
most people it's not a good choice so
before i use the weapon helium and shot
in 8k i used the red epic and shot in 6k
and before that i shot with the red
scarlet and before that i was actually
using the canon c100 back in my college
apartment before that it was the canon
5d mark ii before that the canon 60d and
before that the canon t2i my first dslr
but before that it was the sanyo zakti
cg10
[Music]
the most important statistics really are
that it does shoot in 720p hd at 30
frames a second and 60 frames a second
vga resolution and takes 10 megapixel
photos so here it is guys
fast forward to last week i found one of
these brand new unopened on amazon so of
course i picked one up first thing you
notice out the box is it's way small not
just smaller than other cameras i've
used but even smaller than most
smartphones now probably smaller than
the phone you're watching this on it's
hard to understand exactly what i mean
until you get some scale but it's
rocking a 700 milliamp hour rechargeable
battery so that gives you an idea and a
big selling point for this guy used to
be that it's super portable that's why
it's the pistol grip design it would be
great for vlogging because you could
just turn it around and point it at
yourself you could shove it in a pocket
and just keep it everywhere you go it
fits in places that today's cameras
don't obviously it's not the same
quality as today's cameras but you get
that point for specs it has a 12
megapixel sensor it actually advertises
10 megapixels on the box but that's in
16x9 and you can take it up to 12
megapixels and use that whole 4x3 sensor
if you dig in the menus and it has a 6.8
to 34 millimeter lens so about 5x
optical zoom maybe a little less but it
says 5x and that's from a maximum
aperture of f 3.5 to f 3.7 so not the
widest max aperture in the world but it
can definitely blur backgrounds if you
get the subject close to the camera and
use the old trick of zooming in as far
as you can while being as close to your
subject as possible it does work for any
lens you can create a blurred background
even with the cg10 and it advertised a
60 times digital zoom but we all know
how i feel about digital zoom i've
talked about it before it's about as
fake as the leather on the side of this
camera so no point in using it but
optical zoom is real and it's useful and
that's a big point again a good selling
point for this camera also i like the
warning that hey this this camera might
heat up a little bit while you're
recording but just ignore it that's
supposed to happen but yeah this little
eight-year-old camera shoots 720p video
right to sd cards has mics built in has
this built-in three-inch display which
is again about the same size as some
other cameras out here today has auto
focus even has a macro mode for close
focus and if you get enough light it can
actually take some footage that looks
pretty decent certainly good enough for
youtube in 2017. now okay this is gonna
look a bit different to you because you
just watched a bunch of red footage but
for an eight-year-old camera this does
okay so moral of this tiny story is it's
not all about the quality of the video
it's more about what's in the video
itself so people who are trying to get
started don't have to go buy a great
camera you could probably start shooting
a video right now on the camera on the
smartphone you're watching this video on
so the best advice that i can give to
someone who's trying to start making
videos on youtube is not about what
equipment to buy it's just to start
making videos with what you have now and
then the rest will come so get out there
and create
okay back to your regularly scheduled
programming thanks for watching talk to
you guys in the next one
peace